okay so you know those old games that
used to be in newspapers that would be
like spot the difference between these
two pictures this
this really feels like one of those
games
so we have a new pixel phone ladies and
gentlemen not the pixel six so this was
the uh often rumored but definitely not
cancelled pixel 5a
yeah so they they announced that it
wasn't cancelled but then they never
gave us a real date for it and then they
pre-announced the pixel 6
but now we've quietly got this new pixel
5a it's real
you didn't forget about it did you so
the pixel a series has been great we
already know what it's about right the
great cameras great software overall
value for the money and they've
continued that formula and there's
nothing wrong with that formula
but this is the pixel 5a
and this
is the pixel 4a 5g announced in
september 2020 nearly a year ago
and like i said it's like that game
there are so many unchanged things this
has got to be the smallest
year-over-year refresh i've ever seen
between phones in my life so here let's
just go over all the things that are
exactly the same okay so it's the same
exact specs as last year snapdragon 765
g chip same six gigs of ram
same 128 gigs of storage
same 12 megapixel camera on the back
alongside the same 16 megapixel ultra
wide same back mounted fingerprint
sensor same speakers and same headphone
jack and it's got the same perfectly
fine 18 watt charging and the same lack
of wireless charging so the natural
question is okay it's a new phone what
is actually different what do they
change
so this is where the spotting the
differences game comes in you might have
seen uh the color side by side this is
the easiest thing to spot it is a
slightly new color last year the 4a5 g
was just called just black the new 5a is
literally called mostly black it's
actually a slightly green cast to it so
kind of catches the light nice sometimes
but yeah then it looks like a green
phone but it's mostly black then the 5a
is actually slightly very slightly
larger it's rocking a 6.3 inch 1080p 60
hertz oled display instead of the 6.2
inch 1080p 60hz oled display from last
year same pixel density same hole punch
cut out just a little bit bigger
and then from there there's a bunch of
nice little quality of life improvements
you might not ever know just from
picking up the phone but the longer you
use it the more obvious they would be so
the 5a has a metal unibody construction
now instead of the straight
polycarbonate from last year and you can
hardly tell holding it because they coat
it in this soft touch finish anyway so
it feels kind of like a rubberized type
of plastic but no doubt that's going to
wear better over time and it also lets
them get to ip67 water and dust
resistance which the 4a 5g did not have
and i do like this new textured power
button on the 5a it's got a nice little
accent color and i still love when phone
makers do this honestly they all should
and it's got a raised pattern to id in
your pocket so that's cool
and then on the inside the pixel 5a has
a substantially larger battery so up to
nearly 4 700 milliamp hours and that is
sweet so the last a series pixels were
already quite good with the battery life
because they're not drawing a whole ton
of power again they still all have 60
hertz displays but the 5a's literal
biggest improvement is on something it
already did well so that's totally
welcome long lasting battery is always
good to see but then the only other
things you'd be able to identify you'd
have to check the spec list for uh
gorilla glass 6 on the new one versus
gorilla glass 3 on the 4a5g and they
actually removed the laser autofocus
on the new 5a so
i don't know maybe a bit of a cost
saving move kind of a bummer to see that
now gone
but
at the end of the day that's everything
that's different
old phone
4.99
5a 449 so honestly reviewing this phone
is like the easy part because it's so
similar to last year if you're looking
for a pretty great all-around phone
for a mid-range 500-ish dollar price
other than not having a higher fresh
rate i think this is a pretty safe bet i
mean at this price you're competing
against the samsung a series the iphone
se oneplus nord and a couple others
around there but this one's gonna have
the best camera of that bunch again and
a few nice google features great my
bigger challenge was trying to figure
out
why like why did google just make almost
the same phone 11 months later because
it feels kind of pointless but these
companies don't do things for no reason
there's got to be
a reason so number one i just feel like
there is a pressure if you've started to
do something year over year to just keep
it updated even if it's not a big change
it's not a new chip they didn't add that
many features but if you're just gonna
offer people the latest available
slightly better version
fine but number two
this does have like some weird timing
where it comes around the time where
we're all now thinking about the
upcoming release of the pixel 6 with
tensor they literally already
pre-announced this new more exciting
pixel phone that's coming of course
it'll be much more expensive
but
that means their only choices really
were to do this
or to not release the pixel 5a at all
or
to do 5a with tensor first so when you
look at it that way i guess it sort of
makes sense that we ended up with this i
mean you don't want to debut your custom
new silicon design with a mid-range
phone because then it inherits the
reputation of mid-range silicon possibly
you of course want to put it in the
shiny new pixel six so okay i get that
makes sense and that also likely would
have been a bit too expensive for pixel
5a so i'm sure they just wanted to
release tensor with a new flagship pixel
that's pixel six what's funny is i'm
actually pretty confident based on
conversations i've had with people at
google that they really actually wanted
to launch tensor with pixel 5 that's
what they wanted to do they wanted that
all to line up but things didn't quite
work out and so they ended up moving
tents or back and just pushed pixel 5
out the door with whatever just a
qualcomm chip that worked with it it was
a 765g
and so you might have noticed that phone
also didn't have the neural core and
that other custom silicon that's
supposed to go with the 765g
it just kind of felt like it got rushed
out so now we're waiting for pixel 6. so
pixel 6 will launch tensor pixel 5a is
potentially the last
qualcomm powered
non-tensor powered pixel phone
and so now i think that the biggest
question actually is what is the future
of the pixel a series what will they do
with the next versions
of this and if i was betting
i would think that their best plan would
be
to kind of do the same thing apple does
which is to use the same chip
in the cheaper phone so what apple did
with the iphone se is they use the same
chip that was in the iphone 11 seemingly
overpowered but obviously makes it much
more future proof same deal if they can
use the same tensor chip in pixel
6a that would be ideal then google of
course will save money on the rest of
the hardware around that ship so pixel 6
is a big phone it's a metal and glass
sandwich type thing while the a series
can stay pretty toned down honestly i
think this is a pretty solid metal body
even if it is coated in this rubberized
material it's water resistant it's a
nice size
in a world of sub 500 phones this body
with a tensor chip
should be pretty good now in order for
all of this to work we kind of still
need pixel 6 to do somewhat well there's
a lot actually writing on pixel sticks
doing well we've heard this talk about
them ramping up their marketing efforts
and really trying on this pixel to sell
a lot of them but the reason i bring
that up is they want to sell a bunch
that they start making a lot of them in
mass and manufacturing at a high scale
so that the price of the chip starts to
come down a little bit
and then it makes sense to make a
cheaper phone cheaper body around tensor
and later ship a pixel 6a
because we don't really want
a qualcomm powered 6a as much as we
wanted tensor powered one i would think
so yeah people love the a series and
google couldn't resist drop in a minor
refresh just to get a new
decent phone at this range out the door
makes sense there's a lot of people
waiting for it now you have it there you
go it's pretty good but yeah there's
just a lot riding on pixel six in google
land that's what i'm excited for shout
out to the sponsor of this video
expressvpn so quick question how did you
choose which internet provider that you
use
actually i'll probably just answer that
for you you likely didn't have a choice
or if you did you're pretty lucky
because in most areas you don't have a
choice and so because these isps
essentially have a monopoly over the
areas that they serve if they start
doing things you disagree with or if
they start to track all the websites you
visit even when you're in incognito mode
what are you gonna do switch
you can't so using expressvpn stops this
by rerouting your connection through a
secure encrypted server so your isps
can't see a thing and also rerouting
your connection through a different
server can actually be kind of fun for
example if i want to watch modern family
it's not on us netflix no problem i just
connect to a server that's in the uk
refresh
and i can watch it and it's not just
modern family you can get thousands of
other shows on netflix basically
unlocked just by switching your location
when you use expressvpn so if you don't
want your isp to have complete control
and knowledge over every website you
visit and you want to unlock more shows
it's kind of a no-brainer you can grab
expressvpn today and if you use my code
or go to expressvpn.com
mkbhd that'll get you three extra months
free
thanks again to expressvpn for
sponsoring this video